so we're now entering into 1942 and just
a reminder it's been a little over two
years since the beginning of World War
two in Europe when the Nazis invaded
Poland and even before that as early as
1937 you've had all-out war between the
Chinese and the Japanese and even before
that you've had varying conflicts since
the since the Japanese invasion of
Manchuria in 1931 so Asia has been in
conflict for some time but as we go into
1942 the United States has just entered
into World War two you might remember
December 1941 Japan goes on a major
offensive tries to knock out the US
Pacific Fleet in Pearl Harbor attacks
Wake Island attacks Guam attacks Hong
Kong the Philippines Singapore Malaya
then shortly thereafter goes after other
possessions
Burma goes after the the Dutch East
Indies in its quest for natural
resources and so you can imagine as we
go into 1942 the Americans are eager to
retaliate and in these videos these are
overview videos I'm not going to be able
to talk about every action and every
battle that happens and I'm just trying
to give you kind of the highlights but
the first notable action in 1942 are the
Doolittle raid or is the Doolittle raid
do little raid named after Colonel
Doolittle who who engineers who's the
architect of this raid and the idea is
not so much as a strategic victory but
more of a psychological one if the US
could somehow attack the mainland of
Japan bomb the mainland of Japan would
be huge it would be a more huge morale
booster for the Americans and it might
cause the Japanese people to question
the their own leadership and so the idea
is send out a carrier within bomb or
range roughly a thousand miles off the
coast of Japan and I try to do some
research on where they went but I wasn't
able to find so but roughly a thousand
miles off the coast of Japan and then
send 16 b-25 bombers to bomb the
mainland so 16 bombers to bomb the
mainland and they are actually able to
do this 15 of the Bombers since they
can't land back on to the carrier
they're too heavy and too large to do
that they land 15 of them
in China and then one of them has to be
gets diverted to Russia or the Soviet
Union and out of the 80 crewmen all of
the all of the the the planes get lost
but out of the 80 crewmen three are
killed in action eight are captured and
three are killed in captivity by the
Japanese but for the most part a hugely
successful operation only months after
Pearl Harbor the u.s. is able to attack
the Japanese mainland so one once again
more of a psychological victory than a
strategic one but a major psychological
I guess you could say accomplishment
from the Allied point of view and so
then you can fast-forward so this was in
April then you can fast-forward to May
where you have the first major naval
engagement between the Japanese and the
American Navy and that happens at the
Battle of Coral Sea or the Battle of the
Coral Sea coral Coral Sea which occurs
roughly roughly around roughly over
there and this is significant because
the battle itself it actually the the
the u.s. loses more than the Japanese do
but it is able to [ __ ] the Japanese
Navy enough so that as they go into
their next major offensive they don't
have quite the firepower that they need
and that next major offensive happens in
June happens in June at Midway at Midway
let me make sure you can read this I
know it's hard I don't want to write on
top of Coral Sea so this is in June you
have the Battle of Midway the Battle of
Midway and at the Battle of Midway this
is a Japanese offensive their goal is to
further knock out the United States but
it ends up going the other way and this
is considered a big big big deal this is
the first Japanese naval loss since the
Battle of Shimonoseki straits in 1863 so
you have a u.s. victory here u.s.
victory here a lot of historians even
consider this one of the most
significant naval battles of all times
but you have a u.s. victory here and
once again this is only this is only six
or seven months seven months since Pearl
Harbor
so you have Coral Sea which is able to
[ __ ] the Japanese Navy
maybe cripples a strong word but it's
able to kind of pare them down a little
bit then you have Midway which is a
major u.s. victory and then that takes
us to August August where you have the
Battle of Guadalcanal so you have the
Battle of Guadalcanal where the US there
are several islands over here the US our
time you take it the Japanese want to
retake it
but between kind of the on the ground
forces and the naval forces the u.s. is
able to defeat the Japanese and keep
them from taking Guadalcanal and this is
a big deal because between Midway and
Guadalcanal and 1942 this is kind of the
turning point after this point in a
Midway the Japanese went on the
offensive here the Japanese tried to get
the the u.s. out of Guadalcanal in
August but in both of those the US are
able to to defeat the Japanese at Midway
they're able to kind of fend them off at
Guadalcanal and so this is the turning
point where the u.s. is able to now go
on the offensive
so 1942 is a very very big deal it's
only months after Pearl Harbor months
after the u.s. enters the war but it's
able to start turning the tide and start
to go on the offensive against the
Japanese in the Pacific and what we'll
see in the next video is 1942 also marks
the turning of the tide in Europe